all right B before I jump into this
juicy great episode of fire in the
kitchen juicy it is brought to you by
fancy Guru listen me and Brian are bad
at picks NFL picks college football
picks unless my Buffs UFC picks not our
specialty between us and Drake We're
batting oh for a thousand it is tough
that's why we partnered up with fancy
Guru these are legit experts making
picks for Fantasy Football betting odds
they partnered up with DraftKings so you
can make a more informed pick for your
shot at one million dollar top prize
every Sunday on DraftKings go to The
Experts that's why we hired these people
that's why we jumped the ship on us
making picks and got with the experts
all right and we're going to have the
experts from fantasy Guru they're gonna
jump on the show they can give you their
expert picks so you guys can make money
and get off our backs just go to
fancyguru.com use the code shop that's
sehaub for 20 off that's fancyguru.com
use the promo code shop for twins and
off get the best in In The Biz making
the picks for you so you make bank with
DraftKings fancy guru.com promo code
shop now let's start the show let's
start the show
this is really the fight on the kid come
on baby
I know it's going to be a good podcast
when I I got a lot to talk about do you
today questions I'm glad you do but good
questions I got things I want to get to
I want to get to the bottom of certain
things you know dude I'm excited I'm
excited for coffee zillas uh video come
out on the subject we're talking about
we finally talked about it good to get
off the chest good together
glad I can talk about a little bit but
also you know I'm not I try not to put
my problems on you guys but it was a
stressful situation drove through our
new people yesterday is it is it Orange
County yeah
at 2 30 in the afternoon I have to be
there I'll have to leave at 2 30. I
looked at the GPS it said two hours and
20 minutes I went good
that's my new thing I like this one I
love it I love it because it's so true
like Jocko I wish you'd run for
president I'm gonna use this time for
two and a half hours good didn't get the
promotion good good he's a tough pill to
swallow but it's true 1.6 mil
good yep but then like when I was
dealing with it I didn't call you every
day I'm like hey I talked to this but
how you doing good man dealing with it
that's it good good good
yeah you know but it's true it's like
all problems are there to solve dude
nobody wants to hear it either no good
dude figure it out well hey everybody
we'll figure it out calm down we're good
now I don't know if you saw this or not
but it is going viral Mexico found uh
mummified alien now if you've seen this
little [__] ass alien is that's real
it looks it almost looks like my dick
right like I was like you know that's a
tiny that looks too much like E.T and
here's the thing you know what you know
what the hey Mexico do better it's too
spot on what we think they look shoe
spot on it's also It's Made of Stone
it's a foot look at his stupid neck it's
so bad anything with that skinny of a
neck not scared of dude yeah me neither
and also um it looks like it's made of
oh yeah plaster of Paris paper mache uh
cement but also who knows this 2000
years old back then they're probably
bored as hell they need some
entertainment so someone made these
dolls and then they they mummified it to
mess around and then our dumb asses are
like oh my God look at this alien do you
know it's funny but you just said you
know what I've realized that the
Ancients believed in Aliens too and made
some dolls yeah they're kids that's a
kid's toy do you know what that is
that's two thousand years ago in Mexico
that's their pet monster they mummified
it and now we're like this is real
really dig into it let me see if you
find any bones I talked to a a
congressman uh recently and I said you
know these people are up here you know
claiming they have all this information
about distractions and he said he said
it's not a lot it's not illegal actually
to get up and tell a story no you can
tell a [__] story and you can
actually you're protected on the First
Amendment so you're actually allowed to
lie so these people that get up and
testify in front of Congress it's a
great way to write a book Optics are
great yeah because you're the best PR of
all yes I testified in front of Congress
they didn't want to hear it and the
public thinks because he's in Congress
like this has to be somewhat true people
get in front of Congress all the time
and testify about the biggest bunch of
[__] and you can hear these these
the congressmen they're like I've heard
them they go wait do you really believe
this yeah every time you guys get up to
talk about this subject you have to
bring in the fact that the clintons are
drinking baby blood it's like do you
have any of that one's true but yeah
yeah I mean that part she does have like
blood Marks here so yeah I don't trust
it what just with a straw in the baby's
stomach how easy would it be to figure
out if that money was real hard just
crack that thing open now all you're
gonna find is more cement no they'd be
like no they already got pinatas you
know like I'm a fight bro
it's such [__] it's all a
distraction like isn't it weird how the
alien stuff is popping off right now I
know is that weird but can I ask you a
question what happened to the aliens
that used to abduct rednecks and stick
probes in their ass do they not do that
anymore just curious no you know why
because no one jumped on that narrative
we're like no or so then they keep going
into those guys yeah maybe those guys
had a gay experience and then they had
to blame an alien it was just gay
rednecks yeah they're gay rednecks and
they were like they were ashamed
did it yeah that's a sword it's an alien
everyone's like word word there's
nothing to do about it bro right yeah
that's all that is yeah that's all that
is this is such an easy case to solve
when I saw him like God damn it dude
that is the stupidest looking alien I've
ever seen like and they they have it in
boxes and they unveil it
would you do better than that dude that
is literally E.T literally it's also a
better mummified body than we have it
for humans yeah and it's so obvious
they're tiny and they're they're dude
that's tickle miyomo 2000 years ago
that's all that is
and we're like it's alien and I don't
even buy this 2000 years old but if it
is it's it's them it's some artist who
was like if there was life on Earth dude
how about Rogan has that Samurai in his
Studio yeah like that's a real Samurai
that's about a thousand years old Brian
grabs goes it's not but that's cool
he goes no I'm not buying that it's not
but it's cool it's cool swords real
sword I hope it's not it's not a real
Samurai I looked at the blade it was so
shiny and new and it was like it looked
like it wasn't that folded metal oh yeah
nah I don't think so
I doubt it oh you can see the hips and
all that's there yeah yeah about his
wiener still intact come on yeah
that's so ridiculous that is lame
you are fired hold on go back what does
it say now is this really a alien alien
mommy's in Mexico sign is unveil one
thousand year old corpses have we done
any science on it
yeah I'm not buying it
um let's talk about important things you
talked to Chael Sonnen about the
middleweight division I'd like to get
yeah
it comes out uh shoot same day this
comes out
yeah I want to talk to Chael because he
he knows his stuff when it comes that he
thinks do do policies is screwed he
thinks he's been avoiding uh Anderson
Silva and he thinks it's gonna yeah yeah
sorry Izzy and he thinks gonna bite him
in the butt because he's like there's no
way the UFC gives him a title shot
against Strickland when he turned down
the title shot against Izzy they're not
even like okay that's fine even though
you turn this down here's Strickland
like he walked through no fire I walked
through Whitaker but whenever you turn
down to fight history shows Dana does
not take kind to that he's just like no
do please turn down the fight because he
got injured and then jail doesn't
believe that oh he's like there's no
evident like he said it was his foot we
haven't seen anything wow yeah then he
also said uh right after he beat Robert
Whittaker they were like they're setting
it up Izzy's in the cage he gets out of
the cage that all the media is there he
goes I don't want to talk about Izzy so
he keeps avoiding the Izzy thing down
from the shot he declines that
there's no way he gets it now so we both
agreed we think Paulo Costa Hamza is the
next
the winner of that's the next in line
interesting interesting yeah
um and
but you're saying there is no you're
saying no automatic rematch with Izzy
and I don't think so because you think
Izzy is going to go I think he's going
to take a break let the division figure
itself out oh that'll be tough for him I
know he needs it he's been doing it so
long so active so he needs so I wouldn't
use him into uh uh du policies DDP they
can do it they don't have to be for a
belt there's bad blood there that's the
number one Contender spot so they can do
it six months from the 100 the only
thing is if you're a DDP do you want to
wait six months
because you're out of the conversation
yeah you're not you're not the Talk of
the Town he might really be injured
though he might have a bad foot yeah I
I'm not on the same train as Trail
saying you know he he doesn't think he's
hurt he's probably hurt you know I don't
think he's afraid of anybody but no
something's going on there was avoiding
Izzy I don't know what it is the whole
dynamic maybe the racist thing card they
pull I don't know what's going on there
where yeah but he could get left out of
the party and then Jill had an
interesting thing too he was talking
about asking about Logan Paul Dylan
dancing are you excited do you see
anything because I see all of it I love
it he goes I think it's ridiculous that
he was Logan Paul and Dylan Destiny sit
down in a room together because I
guarantee if Dylan's like hey dude you
asked me to sell this thing what other
narrative could I sell we have no common
opponents you boxed like twice I've
boxed once but what what am I what can I
run with your your fiance is the only
thing I could run with maybe I took it
too far but it's selling a fight yeah
drop drop we're talking about it drop
the lawsuit
yeah oh [__] he's like so you can't sign
a guy like Dylan dance and I expect him
to do this because what he goes what
other angle is he going to go with yeah
that's going to get views it's getting
millions of views you should get Dylan
on here yeah you have me and him been
texting back and forth I like Dylan but
he was saying what else is he going to
do yeah can't talk about the fighting he
knows and he goes I think it's funny too
have you seen in any of their interviews
them talking about oh I'm gonna hit you
with the left hook or he goes there's no
boxing now so it's all personal because
you can't really talk about their
fighting accolades Dylan can talk about
Jiu Jitsu Logan has no background
there's nothing else to talk about so
Dylan being the marketer he is and the
troll he is he's like I'm gonna go for
your famous fiance and that got
attention and now you're suing the guy
he's like that's not what we do he's
like so if they would just sit down I
bet Logan's like all right you're right
I get it you're right you sold this
thing he said because the main they're
not even the main event KSI taught me
Furious when are they supposed to fight
I'm sorry
because is it October or is it September
I think it's October 10th but let me
make sure the thing I'll watch it the
thing is getting in a room you're saying
getting a room without cameras yeah you
can't have your team cameras
yeah you know you can't have any of that
and he thinks if Dylan was like what are
you doing dude now I got this lawsuit
even if I win this fight I get money I'm
gonna end up paying in legal fees like
I'm screwed and for what for selling the
fight and he's he's suing Dylan his
fiance suing okay for for um releasing
an extra defamation defamation I think
his picture didn't belong to him I don't
know I don't know
but she was going to do it from the jump
when he kept doing this stuff and then I
think the thing is all the pictures that
he's pulling is of public consumption
it's all out he's not gonna have some
Insider who's leaking her attack so he's
he's releasing pictures that have
already been out correct
that'll be a tough thing to win in a
court I think agree it's just you still
got to fight it what are you doing Logan
yeah well his wife might be it's his
fiance yes she's probably fiance she's
got her own thing going so she's like
I'm not dealing with this yeah she's
like it might be a tough she might be
like I didn't ask for this I'm not part
of the fight I don't know what the legal
action is there
well so you usually with defamation you
have to prove malice and you have to
also but but in La the judges do not
[__] around with defamation they they
are very very serious about it and you
can get in real trouble for it real
trouble
so you know
um but I get what Jail's saying it's
like what what other nerd was gonna go
on your famous fiance is there you you
he's a notorious troll that's what he
does
this is this is a game he's playing it's
and it's working it's millions and
millions and millions of views well even
this is now
right
the the lawsuit yeah now we're talking
about this there's also like they did a
one-on-one when they talk to each other
so here's a part of it this is uh Logan
Paul
bringing up something from Dylan Dennis
he looks like he's cutting weight there
yeah he looks a little drawn out so
guess what I did
I took the liberty of finding the
bouncer I never choked you out and I
hope he's here yeah remember you got
choked out by a bouncer yeah when he's
drunk
he's in this room right now
[Laughter]
again these kids have no boundaries
because then Logan brings up heels
you've had some friends die and Dylan
dance goes bring up my dad dying go
ahead bring that up let me know how it
goes for you bring it up like what are
you doing Logan but also Dylan what do
you do there's no nothing's off limits
with these yeah that's that's uh that
sucks this was a fun one because
um he mentioned something else about um
what was it so if Dylan wins he gets to
be the best man at Logan's wedding if he
agreed and then if Logan wins he gets
Dylan's entire purse which I think
they're being more playful but that's
better like I like that I like stuff
more and and I'm all about it and those
guys are great here's what I would say
they're they both of those guys don't
need the than to get real personal and
nasty they don't need it well I'm saying
I'm saying that stuff if you think about
it that's that's more witty like I get
into that but if you start talking about
your dad dying now I got sad yeah I
agree I promise Connor and khabib I was
like you're going too far here UFC
completely different animal but with
what they're doing we're not talking
about if Dylan doesn't go down this road
we're not he's gone we're not talking
about meaning if all they're doing is
talking about their fighting accolades
this gets zero traction
zero yeah that's the world we live in
people like this gossip I call it the
Real Housewives of the UFC yeah people
like the gospel until they don't though
so some people will push back on certain
things certain things are sacred to a
lot of people right like you're you're a
dead father or you know I would even
argue you're the your fiancee and if you
start posting internet begs to differ I
think you're off on that I probably am
fortunately I probably am yeah I think
yeah I think you just ages I'm an old
guy but even even I am even at the
fiance stuff I was like but then you're
like at 9 10 11 million views when he
does it so so just seeing that with
those two I'm not good with that I don't
like that stuff I just for me I take it
it's uh
you can tell Dylan's like really you're
gonna go there
talk about that
whatever
[Music]
I empathize with you dealing okay
because I understand the Twitter right
now for you
therapy session yeah because first time
in a while you're getting a sense of
validation it sounds like he said he was
on he was you're gonna talk about my dad
dying is yeah I am but it wasn't like I
got you know what I got from it
your dad never gave you the validation
you're getting it from Twitter and
that's why you're doing it yeah man
that's just it's heavy I'm not into that
track I'm just not into it I'm the wrong
audience I get I just feel but see how
young Their audience is I it makes me
feel even shittier as a result yeah I
think how young even though even young
audiences yeah there's like this morbid
curiosity but part of it's also maybe
when you're younger I remember being
younger and like I remember when Kurt
Cobain killed himself and the people
that I knew I didn't know much about
them but a lot of people I knew were
like haha and yeah you know that's crazy
and I was like and I remember they were
not looking at him as a human being and
when you're young and you haven't lived
a long enough time I'll just say this as
an old man you tend to realize how hard
things can be and also how how tough it
is just you know like all that stuff
that you're six your success you're very
successful right now I promise you that
can be taken away from you so quickly
like that yeah and so until you
understand that when you're young it's
like you're in a free fall and you're
just nothing can touch you invisible and
I get it and and kids are not looking at
the way I look at it maybe I'm a father
it softens you I mean you probably too
yeah when you have kids in the world I
don't know the world becomes just I just
want people to get along man
I do well as Fighters then you have
nothing to get no I'd be the look I'd be
the worst I think I'd be a good trash
talker because I try to be funny but if
you start talking about my
sister my mom my wife I'd be like dude
that's why all you want to do is kill
you that's why they do it they want you
to fight out of control a fight with
anger because you open yourself up to
horrible mistakes yeah I might head
about you to bite you out perfect you're
gonna get knocked out yeah that's why
you're not fired her right
you like to talk to him right no no hold
on
hey that's why you do it
Taekwondo yeah you know I was a wrestler
in high school yep winning record
winning record
you know I'm I'm a boxer yeah well I
wouldn't say you're a boxer you know I
boxed you like the sport of box but you
know I get in there and that's like
saying I'm a basketball you know I get
in there I crack
no you saw me wheel kick now I need you
now I never do this with five fingers
but right now I'm pointing at you with
five fingers and I got a thumb pointing
at those [__] over here Why Us dude
you guys chuckled I didn't joke I got
the whole [__] room unnoticed yeah I
respect you bro okay bro
yeah no I respect him I don't respected
fighting but I respect you as a human
being right it's not just humans
I'll entertain it's a show but there's a
great this Christopher Walken has a
movie called called a comfort of
strangers and the guy goes I just think
you know he makes a statement he's like
makes a kind of a progressive liberal
statement and Christopher Walken plays
an Italian guy and he goes
I respect you I respect to as a man but
not as a fruit fruitcake is it fruitcake
fruit cake you are a fruitcake yes yes
I respect you yeah as a man but not not
as a fruit not a fruitcake or is it
fruit speaking about fruit let's have
some dessert
yeah it's like that you know yeah
you're not a fighter no dude this is my
favorite one guy said this stuff and I
have a little of this in me
when I get mad dude
okay you know what Fighters have never
said when I get I get mad I [__] get
knocked out that starts well no no
Fighters really don't get mad in there
you know it's not you won't hear a
fighter go dude if I get mad I was uh
boxing and I started getting I was
getting check hooked by somebody who's
younger and faster than me and it was
making me
Furious that time I saw you quit
remember that that was the first time I
put on gloves uh in terms of in a boxing
thing not kickboxing because I wasn't
able to use my feet so shut up I was
kind of tired I didn't quit I got so
tired that's quitting that's quick I
can't breathe [__] off
um it was before I learned how to kind
of relax no it's just quitting though
but I forgot to relax
yeah right where I come from what which
I whatever you think where do you come
from we call that quitting yeah but yeah
you're making me mad because I know
because the first time no it's my first
time so I I forgot to breathe yeah
that's all it was once I learned how to
breathe ain't no quitting this dog yep
ain't no equipment
you distracted me what was it what was I
saying what was I saying [__] what was I
saying about
oh yeah he started check hooking me
because he was just faster and I was
getting hit I was trying to jab and I
was getting [__] caught right in the
side of the head and it made me so angry
that well I just attacked yeah probably
got beat up even more and uh no the
coach old school clothes he goes hey hey
hey we're not cracking in here nobody in
here is swinging like that
I don't know what's going on stop stop
trying to really swing on again yeah you
don't and I got anymore though years ago
I don't remember but the point is that
you have a box in years
is it here's it hold on let me think
this is a little so yeah about five
years okay
it's been a long time been a long time
uh yeah and I was embarrassed I got
embarrassed yeah I went you're right
yeah I've never heard of Professor
Anthony go when I when I get mad well
pro athletes get really mad like fabuto
verdum uh against steepe got he just
started chasing him because he got tall
he didn't get back you didn't get mad he
lost his call he he got nothing he lost
his cool he he lunges him before and had
success yeah but I never heard him say
he was right if I get mad he was running
after steepe I think any any fighter can
lose that cool you know I I think he got
caught caught with a check hook and
thinks Donaldson would tell me like what
he did really well when he wouldn't get
emotional
when is anyone in your life who goes
when I get mad is not tough well it's a
liability but people that you're saying
actually fighting saying when they
fought they know that that doesn't work
so they don't say that no no even if
they're not no one says when I get mad
never yeah or the people go I go mental
dude like you don't know it's like do
that I I black out dude yeah okay we
can't now you know how I know he can't
fight yeah yeah you go you blackout oh I
go numb dude yeah but you've never been
punched I see red okay yeah until you
get hitting the liver punch in the face
real hard and all of a sudden you're
sober up right quick after you wake up
yeah back to Dylan Dennis I think it's
just the route he had to sell the fight
shouldn't be sued for it yeah I don't
agree with it but you made a deal with
the devil there is there is something
called going too far in everything right
yeah Conor khabib was a bit of that
you know we talk about someone's
religion and stuff like that and oh I
didn't like that yeah I don't like that
but then they gotta fight yeah
that's what's great about the UFC is
then eventually you have to fight and
then we'll find out double face kicked
Dylan Dennis and yeah look what happened
after the fight yeah it spilled over
hey sometimes I'm gonna tell you this
right now when I drink my coffee dude
I'm sick of black coffee I'm like I wish
there was something out there you don't
drink Dairy no I don't do you know I
don't do that hey but are you a baby no
no listen I understand milk's for babies
it's for babies I'm not baby on you no
man I'm not a grown man and you don't
want to drink the milk of another animal
that's coming out of the tit well what
about nut milk and I'm not talking about
I'm talking about macadamia nut milk Oh
I thought okay I'm talking about
Macadamia okay so I don't want that kind
of nut I'm talking about pure macadamias
the milk from Pure magazines no added
sugar silky smoothies milk added no
added oils sugar stabilizers
preservatives like all the other nut
milks contain okay it's environmentally
friend it comes as Macadamia milk paste
with water at home so no water transfers
dude if you tell me you're gonna give me
a free gallon of macadamia milk when I
visit House of macadamias.com
do you know how much do you know how
much a gallon of macadamia milk is five
thousand dollars just spitballing here a
gallon is outrageous and it'll last you
the rest of your [__] life
I had so much they're actually giving
away because you're just using a little
splashing sauce for the first time I'm
gonna be honest with you look at my face
like uh guys you're giving a little free
gallon of macadamia milk when you visit
House of macadamia.com
t-f-a-k all right just add the milk to
your cart with any products the
chocolate covered Mac demon nuts the 45
macaroni and nut bars the variety pack
you get a gallon of macadamia milk a
gallon a gallon is Gonna Last you
forever forever well forever is the
answer how's Mike Davis went let's give
someone Macadamia milk who was in The
Boardroom and went we can give them some
packets I got an idea give them a gallon
gallon well then they're never gonna buy
it again he goes That's yeah that's okay
free that's a lot that's awesome
macadamus.com
we were putting in our coffee by the way
and just add the milk to your cart with
any products and use the code tfak enjoy
your gallon yeah that was that that was
the ugliest the UFC's ever been that was
tough and Ellen just said and then on
his Twitter today that he has a lazy eye
from training with Connor that fight
Connor broke his orbital [__]
[__]
that's serious so he was boxing with
Conor a lot yeah he trained with him all
the time start off as juicy coach I
think training with him it's been
interesting how Dylan does against Logan
you know I don't know Logan bigger than
him right
ah Dylan's not small man it's not yeah
but I mean less miles on Logan all
Logan's been doing his focus on boxing
as far as Combat Sports goes you would
decide with Dylan but
I don't know man Logan is a big look at
that that's uh That's Mike Perry oh okay
he's [__] huge
is he really might short yeah is he
faced off there for real is that a real
Face-Off with Mike hurry up because he's
the back he's the backup
which would be a nightmare that's a
nightmare for for 11. yeah I love your
name beat Mike Perry
no Mike Perry is at least Beast
oh they're talking about them
followed Pete broken feet broken fingers
[Music]
swallow teeth broken feet broken fingers
this has been a war zone
and that comes from Sean O'Malley saying
you always have a lazy eye or just
sometimes sorry high as [__] right now
can't tell
oh my God
damn what is a zygomatic Arch
that's a great question something in the
eye right for some reason I thought it
was your foot
Bridge of bone extend from the temporal
bone at the side of the head around the
upper jaw bone Jesus Christ how would
you get hit dude
get lit up dude how about my boy and
Rogers out for the year
some speculate I don't agree with this
some speculate for good he's 39. he's 39
I mean blown Achilles and it was a full
rupture I think right full rupture you
know better I mean
I don't know what it's like to be in
Rogers I know there's not a more
competitive person on this Earth and I
doubt he goes out like that and with
science and technology they could get
him back by next year you're crazy if
you think Aaron Donald's gonna I mean
Aaron Rodgers and go out like that
there's no way he's not on no no
the bummer is there's the star receiver
as he's getting caught off he looks him
goes sorry kid because he would have
made that kid's life dude that kid would
have been all pro sorry sorry kid that
sauce Gardener that made me that made me
cry want to cry sorry kid he knew he
knew didn't oh everyone knew yeah so
when he I knew five minutes into it you
did I got confirmation five minutes into
it yeah oh
from someone that works on the Jets
because I was like oh I was texting the
guy I'm like maybe it's just a high
ankle sprain he was nope fully ruptured
Achilles out for the year does that mean
the Achilles snapped yeah snap oh oh my
God it was it get it I was bummed for
the entire night yesterday I've been
bummed all week about it yeah it's just
one of those things freak accident third
play of the game freak accident
39 years old it could be the turf you
know
that's why they shouldn't play on turf
but again is it turf or is it the way he
was tackled is the ground be more
forgiven probably with the dirt that's a
minimum year isn't it oh yeah no chance
he comes back this year not happening so
the Jets have Zach Wilson who's
contoriously known for not being very
good uh that kid who was who played
finished the game yeah he was the
starter last year how does uh Josh Allen
feel after throwing three interceptions
like that and losing it'll get better
he's a monster he's a monster monster
just one of those days what was it Jets
have a great defense too the best yeah
some someone if they want to some vet
who's chilling being an analyst right I
can step in there and you got a great
offense and defense they're stacked
they're made to people they're made to
be a Super Ball run that's why I tweeted
out I went horrible having my boy and
Rogers what's at Tom Brady up to is he
he's retired yeah he's retired
officially and Aaron Aaron Rodgers if
there's one guy who wouldn't let's step
in it's Tom Brady like [__] no
and and when the Super Bowl I'm supposed
to win [__] that's such a bummer for
Aaron Rodgers oh I've been bummed all
week because the Jets are a great team
and they just need well they're a good
team and they had the right places they
just never had a quarterback and you get
one of the best ever do it first
holidays four plays in four plays in
seemed like a bad dream [__]
[__] that's football it was a good game
too just a freak accident man
um what would you say do you think
they'll get a quarterback can they do
that is it a few guys out there of
course Colin Kaepernick's crying uh he's
not the answer uh Kaepernick yeah
they're still saying I'm ready to go
it's like eight chill
um that's yup Philip Rivers out there
you got Carson Wentz Philip Rivers yep
Philip Rivers still down is he is he it
but he's been playing for since he's old
as dirt too but with that team man you
get a vet he's a great quarterback but I
mean I feel like he's been is he retired
or is he yeah he played for the Colts
then he retired so we'll see what he
does he's a free agent or whatever yeah
he's got to be 40. no he's uh late he's
a killer
41 dude
41. we gotta calm down right we all got
to calm down so a little that's a lot of
that's a lot of years Tom Brady is 45.
I mean
all right and then give me give me the
next one what was the name uh Joe Namath
uh
three still playing RG3 could play he's
still available he's not still playing
he's an analyst for ESPN of course yeah
Carson he's not the answer no I know
that Carson Wentz they'd rather person
wants to be good is he he's available
he's available he got cut by the Colts
oh hey Carson Wentz is good what
happened why did he get cut
yeah he got injured he was having an MVP
season was supposed to win MVP when they
won the Super Bowl the Nick Foles came
in and he just hasn't been the same
since that injury
oh
man yeah they're in a tough position
because it's it's a great opportunity
for somebody you know what I bet you
guys who want to get traded like when um
homeboy Lamar Jackson for Baltimore get
traded even though he got paid now I bet
he's like damn
you know what I said when uh
when Aaron Rodgers towards a kill is
good
you think Aaron Rodgers woke up Monday
morning went they went uh complete
rupture you're out for sure this season
maybe for the rest of your life good
luck good
not even Jocko could talk him into a kid
mood hey Jocko calls hey Jaco you know
what this stuff happens life good yeah
Aaron's like yeah thank you thank you
there's nothing it's like I was like I
was a camp counselor I was a counselor
for [__] debate team and they they I
we didn't none of the counselors on the
floor and they tore up the whole dorm
they tore it all up before they rubbed
the ceilings and I go I found out who
had started I go I go
what the [__] and he was he goes like
this he goes sorry I couldn't say sorry
he goes out of control oh my God I went
Tasmanian devil on it ah yeah I don't
know what the Jets are gonna do I bet
they stay with uh homeboy who's playing
right now
that's what I bet they do and they lose
first round of the playoffs
because he just have an awesome awful
luck yeah Zach Wilson you know he
doesn't quite have it no just does it
young kid from BYU
Johnny Manziel
Johnny's out there
it's tough dude I mean you can't
unreal
unreal you love that guy oh yeah love
Aaron unreal
it's not Rage of all good of all the
injuries too like that's the worst
injury oh ACL MCL would be better break
if you broke your neck better
all better broken arm better
that's actually true getting covered
better
well yeah
even HIV we can figure that out we can
manage that you can still play
blown Achilles cat dog yeah what do you
do
good yeah let me get back now what
happens to his contract
yeah a portion of it's guaranteed
um he's guaranteed so he's pretty set so
they tell you the proportion they take a
bath though they yeah but I don't know
if it counts against the cap salary so
they'll be able to bring somebody in
good if you're the Jets good
I don't know man it's a tough one to
swallow
at his age
makes me sad let's bring Chad Pennington
back
did Joe Namath drunk ass up there
yeah
God maybe someone from the 49ers one of
the Garoppolo or Lance I know Lance they
traded you got you got uh Donald who was
there I love that Colin Kaepernick is
still making noise like he's not though
he's only making those noise with
dumbasses like Jamal Jameel Hill or
whatever her name is she's like I know a
guy who would do it it's like shut the
[__] up
how about no you had your moment come on
yeah you don't want to play you want to
be a poster boy you don't want to play
he's more valuable off the field for
them yeah not even anymore no those days
are over
what do you got good yeah he's always
gonna be like hey what's up
they said his tryout that he had for
Atlanta was like the worst drought
they've ever seen I'm sure that heike
was like throwing the ball I'm like
Jesus Christ Smith broke it down too he
was like why would he want to practice
at this facility not at this one he was
an hour or two or three or four hours
late there was a whole bunch of stuff he
was trying to like make it on his terms
you just want attention no he did
everything he could yeah he just and
then he wants to be like look they're
keeping me out of it because it keeps
his name in the site news cycle you
don't want to play no just to [__]
unless you're like okay here's the ball
go
then he was calling his parents racist
it's like yeah because they it's like
hey dude you are a [__] baby
yeah he's a little [__]
what are you doing what do you got Jen
well Brandon you were right about that
train so when people are talking about
it they're saying that he has like women
they're like fan you're like that sing
for him and all this stuff he gets
Lobster a bunch of all these like really
like the uh I'm surprised you guys
didn't jump on that literally no pun
antenna I'm surprised you didn't jump on
that train he goes that thing looks
terrible like you think Kim jong-un's
riding a boring train no no dude a train
and a sock goes a long ways dude look at
all the tires look at all those old men
with the photographers it's just yeah
I'm just gonna say this you're out of
your mind if you don't think if I was on
the train I have the biggest dick in the
train
look at those people you're out of your
mind if we didn't have a dick size
contest if I don't did the Dominate that
dick contest
right everyone in this room would
dominate okay just looking at hey why
don't you dare hey
if there's odds here me and Brian are
minus seven thousand here I would
imagine that's probably and I've seen
Brian's and I'm gonna lose
cheers I got a juicy dick and I'd like
to run down that aisle with my pants
down just naked and be like hey guys I
just like the streak oh I'm the Tom
Brady of that room I'm reigning MVP yeah
and here we go Tommy Lee man oh man
sitting around their suits all right
fellas
has a more robust figure yeah hey fellas
I know you could kill me check this out
check out this python yep and by the way
isn't it funny how if we were in North
Korea you and I right now would be doing
hard labor or we'd be shot to death for
this conversation Sydney is a little
dick or just singing no I'm saying it's
a little to mine
robust character he's not been missing
any meals no
live lobsters no nor would you so they
accounts really detailed crates of
Bordeaux burgundy wines live lobsters
by young female singers dude introduced
as lady conductors
this is the greatest trade of all time
dude Lobster and a dick suck a nice
color too a nice green
you know me I love green yeah that's my
[__] you're wearing green right now ah I
think about I always I want on you know
what I think about with Saddam the same
same thing like if you were ever late
you're dead you're dead like so you
don't have to sleep dude there's Rush
Hour
you're like [__] you'd be dead is off
Saddam you would have died 10 years ago
dead yeah dead some of the mistakes
Jin's made not many
once too many if you're Saddam Hussein
dead yeah yeah
you're not George you send a thumbnail I
don't like it Dad
that didn't end well for Saddam though
you don't want to run a business like
that no awful yeah good dad though but
Putin Putin looks like he's got some uh
he's got some filler in his cheeks
something's going on you think he got
some little Botox go back to Putin he's
70. uh look up how old Putin is for a
sec he's also sick supposedly
he's 70 yet yeah and and look at that
picture bring up a couple pictures of
him he's looking very
uh you know puffy there that's not a
good picture the Russians aren't the the
healthiest group of people
yeah vodka and sausage ain't gonna do it
and wait this is great go back can you
go back to you about anybody
Sean Penn go to Sean Penn and all those
guys now Sean's about 10 years younger
than them he's a rough life he's yeah no
one has run it harder than Sean Penn yes
the amount of Legend the amount of
smoking drinking and and coking is on
another level dude over under how many
girls have the three of them [__]
ten thousand you know I think Sean
picked his spots oh but picked his spots
being holes in the wall yeah but I don't
think anybody compares to Putin and I
don't think I don't know if anybody
compares to Trump trump put it down
Trump or Putin put it down dude yeah
they put it Putin though it's like if
you don't suck them you dying well so so
I have a story about that the you know
remember the woman who played La Femme
Nikita
this is from a very reliable source who
was there is she Russian yeah bring up
La Femme Nikita actress those were big
movies yeah right there Peta Wilson
bring her up for a sec gotta I got a
real story for you about this oh yeah so
when she was yeah when she was younger
check out the jaw or something else
right there you go oh and by the way
she's a tall strong and my boner am I
right Fellers back there yeah that's a
big strong girl
now Putin was obsessed with her
apparently and in fact Putin this is
you're gonna love this I don't know if I
ever told you this story and I this is a
story from a very famous person who was
at the Kremlin
so Putin invites Peter Wilson because he
was a huge fan of the show and her we
all are and she gets there with her
boyfriend look at that right there she
gets there with her boyfriend oh yeah
I'd move guess what
the boyfriend
gets
first of all I also know from this
famous guy that that guy Putin had
basically what you'd basically orgies
like that you'd just be a party it's
poon dude he's Putin and he's a gangster
the biggest gangster on the planet
well apparently her boyfriend gets
locked out on a balcony where that could
happen to anybody just locked out on a
balcony yeah and Putin takes her into
like some other room in the Kremlin
showing her around just Charming the
[__] out of her and that guy was out
there for three hours until Putin had
laid his groundwork and he was like what
the [__] and she was like what happened
I couldn't find you this I got a lot
they locked me out on the ground what
are you doing she's like
yeah he was outside somewhere on some
Courtyard couldn't get back in he's like
excuse me yeah yeah sorry dude did the
boyfriend come this way they want to
show you something and lock them out and
then they were like oh sorry we didn't
see you he was like are you [__]
kidding and Putin's does she speak
Russian I don't know I don't know Peta
Wilson my guess is she's American and
she's she's just a you know
see how tall well then it gets awkward
because the translators he'll be like he
says he wants to
she's Australian Australian oh wow how
tall is she Andre a model because
Putin's a not a tall guy
I don't think it matters I think yeah
see I don't think he cares about height
she's 5 10. There You Go Bubba that's
tall for a girl that's a dog
and Putin's five ten
no no shorter he's about five seven bro
Vladimir five seven seven that's a not a
big guy that's like Casey
you know sure and we'll kill you friend
a group called the KGB oh yeah I've
heard of them or poison you with
plutonium or whatever what else you got
Jen
let's go to this one right here an
orangutan in uh Australia so this is
this tree house and then he found a or
he or she found a possum and just flung
it so
you gotta get out of my tree house too
they only caught the ass end of it but
what'd you think was gonna happen
it's like there you go
why are those people so scared you hear
me in the back like awesome is that is
that is that what happens to me if you
find me in your bed yeah yeah I get
shocked yeah dude so wait just like that
just like that if I'm like I can explain
and then you just you just I I want to
figure out the rank thing but the pot or
the pause the ranking grab the possuma
is two feet like see they got hands like
this oh there's a huge pants like that
what else can I see can I see that again
because I want to see him throw it
I wish they caught the beginning of him
going up there and be like hey hey let
me talk to you
yeah oh that's all we got where's it at
it's in Australia I'm guessing it's an
Australian zoo that is [__] oh he's
[__] up
a possums that doesn't look like a
possum though because it has a thick
tail maybe it's brilliant possums a
little different oh look at the big
bushy Tails
Earth Perth Zoo get out hey get the [__]
out of here
all right so look like a lemur yeah
either way things dead so there's a oh
hold on one sec before this one
that's Australian possums so those are
cute cuter than our trash possums here
oh yeah ours are oh look at these guys
oh he's cute that one's dead that we
showed on the video but they're cute
yeah that one that one's not good their
noses are delicious
look at their little snouts
possums in general are wet yeah they are
I like I enjoy it possum I think they're
cool thank you
um so there's been a Manhunt for this
guy for a while now Danilo cavakante
yeah the caught him in a Manhunt and
they used actual airplanes with thermal
Detectors of heat and all that stuff to
catch them why did it take foreign
because he killed someone in Brazil
right that his mom says was trying to
kill him that's so it was justified
that's what his mom's saying and then
his girlfriend was arguing with him but
after she found out that she killed
someone in Brazil and then he killed her
in front of the kids yeah he killed her
in front of the kids or the kids were
there stabbed him 14 times in front of
the kids
yeah they're probably like hey [__]
we've been out in the forces 14 days
we're gonna get ours and this is how he
escaped I don't know if you've seen this
video yet oh it's some Parkour [__] here
yeah so his buddy's on the look Outlook
he's like just watch look his friend
his friend with the Hamza beard look at
him go yeah they said crab walked up
hell
damn he's just really good at escaping
this is good
and he broke into multiple houses got
stuff he's got a truck he found a truck
he would win squid game tell you that
right now yeah man but 14 days on the
lamb you know how large that is I'll get
you
no fine but he was only like a mile half
away that's what's impressive that's why
he must be super good I think about I
think about something else
I think about the fact that we live in a
surveillance state where they can find
you anywhere like they they can they
have facial recognition technology and
so what was happening was any camera was
was sending a message somewhere because
like they were like they they have
access to every one of these cameras
you're always on camera and I think to
myself damn
you're not getting away with anything no
he got away with a 14 days Brian yeah
but they caught him they kept having it
they kept catching them on security
cameras though they kept catch them on
ring cameras but he kept breaking the
homes yeah getting supplies yeah the
ring cameras not like CIA cameras dude
wow still ring there's a mile away
14 years only a mile away yes dude he
was chilling he didn't he didn't really
go first they should use him for finding
other people you know what I mean yeah
be like what did you do to get away like
how are you able to go undetected these
days were these with hundreds of people
searching for it entire neighborhood
looking for I think see who was I think
they mobilized a team of guys like that
looks like they look like professional
soldiers yeah they don't look like cops
what gave that away the camo yeah and
the uh equipment tactical teams from
Pennsylvania State Police FBI and border
patrol yeah
yeah tactile units I think how many
people they use to catch him hey click
on how did they find him like what gave
them away I know people like several
people saw him because he broke in their
homes yeah one guy shot at him but he
didn't have a bullet on him like he did
he didn't get hit he so he stole that
guy so he broke into an apartment stole
the guy's gun and then so they told him
yeah there's someone here alerted the
authorities then they had an airplane
and people come out and they still
couldn't find them so the next morning
they did it again in this general area
and then the airplane with that thermal
whatever you know detector was able to
get him and then the ground true
Tactical Unit dog ultimate pinned him
yeah so it wasn't even the dudes they
knew where he was and the dog is the one
I actually got him wow that's why it's
all good that's cool yeah the dog he's
having a hard time that dog is a hero
he's not having it and he didn't fight
back or anything he's like yeah
but for him it's like you got two life
sentences like yeah dude do your thing I
mean he's staying in jail the rest of
your life
yeah I don't know
alrighty I had one here and give me a
sec oh here's a quick one so this is
Tracy Cortez UFC fighter she went on a
UFC live and I guess someone
did what they did to cat when we did
that game oh what game remember that
game we were like I was on screen and
the cow was on screen oh my God
oh my God
somebody just flashed his big [__] I
guess
look at my dick like come on dude yeah
well here's my thing they do it has it
ever worked we're like oh my God that
looks tasty there must be some like
super horny chicks out there crazy
chicks the numbers aren't good yeah it
can be good odds one out of 10 000.
weirdo I mean this freaks out there
girls that are freaks who knows all
right this is the last one I have this
is a GOP rep Lauren Boberg she got
kicked out of a beetle a Beetlejuice
musical with a stranger I think she
recently got divorced or is going
through a divorce with her husband so
she was with a stranger but check her
out she looks
I mean she's the Heavies so she was
apparently she's the government heavy I
mean they look insane she was apparently
vaping and making a ton of noise that's
why they had to kick her out sounds like
a good time and you'll see her here and
then she argued with security but watch
check her out check out these sweater
puppies they're coming up right now
check out these White House hitters when
they come through yeah oh boy boom
there's more
oh what was the problem she was vaping
in a musical making too much noise you
know musicals you're not supposed to
choose vaping or giant tits with
distraction Brian I mean she looks hot I
had no idea she was just hot yeah me
neither and she's from uh I think she's
she's a congresswoman in Denver or
Colorado she's got yeah this is nine
news that's my old stomping ground shout
out to Ron zapolo Kathy Saban she's just
dancing with their their partner well
you know unidentified dude is that is
that her husband no unidentified so
obviously someone she's seeing or dating
that's the guy going to get his wiener
out between his two big tits
she's a cutie she's a cutie pie yeah man
man no privacy though
I think she's cute no everybody does it
yeah yeah I'm not the only one of them
lately yeah
yeah she's hot yeah she's hot that's how
it's extreme in her views I think but
she's hot and I don't need to listen oh
dude I convert to whatever view she
whatever whatever yeah I agree yeah I'll
vote for Biden but I agree with you
those tits
oh really oh yeah pick her up she's
hardcore concerned oh wow
and owns a gun and as a gun gun toting
uh Second Amendment good and and
literally literally you'll see her you
see her and and she'll be interviewing
with some some journalist who's like you
know the journalist is like well gender
is a spectrum or whatever and you're
pathetic though you're pathetic wow
because no we won't spend more money
she's in the freedom caucus or she's
like no we won't we won't spend more
money
freedom caucus I'm about to bust your
caucus is huge
this caucus is out of control you got a
dong on you is that itching that's it
ladies we did it again I'm in Spokane
next Thursday Friday Saturday Spokane
comedy clubs next Thursday Friday
Saturday September 21st to the 23rd I
mean beer skank Fest September 29th 8
P.M we have a live final kid with me in
the skank Fest crew and and Brian and
that's September 29th and 30th we're
doing stand-up all around the skank Fest
festival and then uh I'm in Iowa October
13th and 14th one show Friday one show
Saturday
Niagara Falls uh that's Friday Saturday
Chicago Friday Saturday only those
tickets available right now at
thickboy.com but Spokane Washington come
get you some
funny bone this Friday this Saturday
come get some uh Omaha Nebraska I'll see
you there briancallen.com Comedy Zone
Greenboro North Carolina Friday Saturday
October 6th and 7. I'll see you then all
right kids love you be nice to each
other